l'homme fort du pays c'est lui le
lieutenant colonel mamadou doumbouya il
a la réputation d'être un officier
aguerris instruits pour la mine guirassy
journaliste et fondateur du groupe à
d'infos médias guinée est le chef de la
junte affiche une volonté de vouloir
rassembler autour de lui pour former un
gouvernement de transition on écoute il
a enfin d'une consultation ce que d'ici
la semaine prochaine
tout peut aller très vite en tout cas de
ce côté pour
mettre un gouvernement d'union nationale
on voit déjà des déclarations de
certains partis politiques qui disent
ouverts 2 pourquoi adhérer compte dr
ousmane kaba qui est du paresse qui a
collaboré à un moment donné aussi avec
alpha condé donc des choses se font avec
qui qu'est ce qui peut se passer dans
les heures à venir dans les jours à
venir ce qui concernant ce gouvernement
de consensus d'union nationale on verra
bien c'est un civil à la tête si cinq
militaires à la tête je pense on dit que
les gens ont compris que il fallait se
rallier c'est comme ça je le dis donc de
ce côté
ci dimanche encore il y avait quelques
tirs par un droit aujourd'hui
ça s'est calmé